bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct c'est parti pour un nouveau
tour de l'actrice porte du département
passe tout de suite au titre en images à
cinq jours de la reprise du championnat
de france élite de foot us les templiers
d'elancourt peaufinent leurs
combinaisons prêt à aller chercher le
titre national avec leur nouvelle recrue
américaine
nous nous envolerons dans cette édition
dans les airs pour la cinquième édition
de l'eee top avec philippe guiraud cette
compétition internationale de modélisme
organisé aux clayes-sous-bois le
week-end prochain où seront réunis les
meilleurs pilotes du monde et enfin en
des missions nous vous ferons découvrir
l'aïkido est un art martial méconnu
réunion réunissant de nombreuses
techniques de combat la discipline est
en train de s'ouvrir au plus grand
nombre par le self défense et comme
d'habitude en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du week-end mais tout d'abord
au passo foot us et à la reprise des
templiers en championnat de france élite
à cinq jours de la reprise du
championnat de france élite de foot us
les templiers d'elancourt peaufinent
leurs combinaisons je le disais dans les
titres prêts à aller chercher le titre
national avec leur nouvelle recrue
américaine sean shenton jonathan
willeman pour les images il est la
nouvelle gâchette des templiers le jeune
quarterback américain shaun shelton a
débarqué à elancourt tout droit du
missouri il ya trois semaines il va
avoir la lourde tâche de faire oublier
le phénomène vini me roth il s'est bien
intégré dans l'équipe ils en sont bien
il peut courir c'est ce qu'on attendait
c'est ce qu'on avait vu sur les vidéos
lorsqu'on l'a recruté donc pas de
mauvaises surprises
alors on est on est très content il a
fait un bon match amical la semaine
dernière cette saison mickaël marion
s'occupe de la ligne d'attaqué manu
charest de la défense une nouvelle
organisation qui n'a qu'un seul but
l'objectif clairement ces finales et
titre pour faire mieux que l'an dernier
bon s'arrêter en demi-finale on a perdu
de peu contre le flash ça nous a laissé
un petit goût amer je pense qu'avec les
recrues d'intersaison
le reste de l'effectif qui restent
inchangées et stable je pense qu'on
avait rien d'atteindre cet objectif
après un début de saison idéal l'an
passé avec cinq victoires en autant de
journées des templiers avait connu un
énorme trou d'air et trois défaites
consécutives qui leur avait coûté la
première place en 2014 avec un
championnat réduit à neuf équipes ils ne
devront pas se louper il ya qu un match
cette année donc on n'a vraiment pas le
moment pas le choix c'est là pas le
droit à l'erreur il n'y a pas de joker
cette année premier acte ce samedi sur
le terrain des kangourous de pessac
il les templiers participeront cette
saison à la première édition de la
champion's league de foot us en europe
avec l'arrivée de cette nouvelle
compétition le calendrier n'est
toutefois un pas trop chambouler car le
championnat de france est moins
conséquent que la saison dernière avec
une équipe de moi en lice comme le
disait manu charest dans le reportage
que vous venez de voir les templiers se
retrouve donc dans un groupe à trois
avec londres et barcelone ils pourront
donc jouer leur chance à fond dans cette
compétition en fonction de la fraîcheur
physique de l'effectif
ce sera des matches qui seront en fin de
saison donc je verrai en fonction
surtout de l'effectif et de monde en
sera si on a des blessés ou pas
pour pouvoir effectivement
de pouvoir entre guillemets faire des
priorités sur les objectifs mais bon
chez que les gars ont fait un super
motivés pour pour pour jouer cette
compétition et l'emporté donc
on va tout faire pour on passe désormais
à notre portrait de la semaine il
s'appelle garé à 106 les jeunes
entrepreneurs de 30 ans yvelinois bien
sûr il y a cinq ans il fonde une société
spécialisée dans la vente de pièces
détachées le vélo en tout genre
désormais avec 20 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en 2013 il veut
s'exporter à l'étranger étienne langue
pour les images quand on voit gary
marché dans les allées de son stock on
n'imaginerait pas une seule seconde que
dix ans plus tôt ce compétiteur de vtt
au niveau national et européen
je suis telle ou heureusement lors d'un
entraînement je suis cassé la colonne
vertébrale j'ai été immobilisé un peu
plus d'un an j'ai découvert internet et
le e commerce à ce moment là parce que
je pouvais plus bouger et de ma passion
en fait j'essaie transposer ça sur un
modèle commercial donc le e-commerce et
l'aventuré n'est en mai 2008 donc autour
du vélo c'est donc de son lit que gary
se lance dans la vente de pièces
détachées accessoires pour vélos et
donne naissance à ault rixe avec
seulement 6000 euros six mille c'est
aussi le nombre de mètres carrés sur
lesquels est désormais installé son
entreprise
aujourd'hui hall tricks et 45 salariés
dix sept mille références en stock et un
chiffre d'affaires en 2013 de 20
millions d'euros à 30 ans gary compte
bien passer au braquet supérieur
la majeure partie de l'activité est
concentrée sur la france aujourd'hui est
le challenge pour 2014 ces deux
d'avancé sur des pays comme le portugal
l'espagne l'italie où il ya peu de sites
internet dans le vélo aujourd'hui et
pour autant beaucoup de pratiquants de
consécration pour l'entreprise de gary
après le vélodrome nationale hall trick
sera partenaire d'aso pour le tout
premier rock paris où se donneront
rendez-vous des milliers de vététistes
du 28 au 30 mars prochain à mantes la
jolie
allez on passe à notre page spéciale
modélisme
en
fin de semaine pendant trois jours les
clayes-sous-bois accueille la 5e édition
de l'ipl tournoi international indoor de
paris de modélisme vous avez vu
d'ailleurs un des avions devant vos yeux
tout à l'heure qui est juste devant moi
sur cette table du 7-8 sport dont vous
êtes l'organisateur d'ailleurs de
l'étape philippe guiraud bonsoir à vous
merci d'être présent tout d'abord
comment se décompose une épreuve de
voltige puisqu'on va assister à de la
voltige ce week-end bah c'est à dire
c'était une épreuve de voltige veut
imposer donc avec des figures imposées
avec différentes catégories vous avez la
promotion qui permet aux jeunes et moins
jeunes d'ailleurs de se lancer dans
cette compétition la catégorie nationale
un peu plus compliqué et finalement 1
catégorie internationale qui est
pratique et non de dans leurs comptes
hier vend dans le monde entier alors il
y aura de nombreux pilotes 1,63 pilotes
présents ce week-end aux
clayes-sous-bois les meilleurs du monde
je vous propose de regarder un petit
extrait de l'excellent éditions
précédentes l'année dernière pour voir
un peu ce que ce à quoi cela ressemble
oui
philippe la moindre des choses que l'on
puisse dire c'est que c'est envoûtant
quand même c'est un ballet incroyable
très envoûtant et en fait là ce que vous
avez montré c'est en fait il ya deux
concours dans cette compétition il ya
concours de voltige à poser est dans ce
qu'on vient de voir le concours de vol
en musique qui a la même ambiance à la
entre les deux balles au volant mieux
les nouveaux la musique cd biture
totalement libres le pilote fait ce
qu'il veut choisi sa musique alors quand
virulent imposé bombes allaient les
figures sont imposés par la fédération
et ryan internationale qu'est ce qu'on
peut voir justement comme figures
imposées
dans le langage profane c'est des
loopings des tonneaux des renversements
une combinaison des deux joueurs des
trois on arrive à des figures qui n'ont
pas vraiment de noms connus du grand
public très complexe quel est le type
d'épreuve que vous préférez vous puisque
je sais que vous êtes aussi pilote à la
place de temps en temps aux
organisateurs mais aussi pilar d'une
tout à fait oui mais moi je ne fais que
de l'imposer que j'ai pas de libre
musique alors on envoie un des exemples
est un peu ici sur la table du 7-8 sport
ça pèse combien laquelle et l'envergure
et les caractéristiques de ce modèle là
c'est un peu le type d'avion qu'on
pourra voir ce week-end
aux clayes-sous-bois donc il fait sous
80 centimètres d'envergure 80 cm de
longueur et il fait 80 87 g exactement
en or de vol avec la batterie c'est
ultra légères c'est très très léger ça
veut dire que ce genre d'avion ne peut
pas voler en extérieur c'est réservé
exclusivement aux démonstrations indoor
ah oui ça en extérieur c'est c'est
carrément impossible le moindre souffle
d'air il part et pour vous donner une
petite idée quand on vole en gymnase on
coupe les chauffages du gymnase à ce
point là alors pour vous quand on
préparé l'émission vous me parliez de la
conception spécifique de ces modèles
racontez nous un petit peu de quoi c'est
fait en fait c'est fait de plaques de
d'éperons qui est à l'origine fait pour
faire de l'isolation dans les maisons on
a un peu détournée de son usage premier
don qui est ajouré et recouvert avec de
la feuille de miller pour que ce soit le
plus léger possible c'est totalement
artisanale ça veut dire qu'on trouve pas
ça dans le commerce s'il existe des kits
dans le commerce mais qui sont souvent
beaucoup beaucoup plus lourd et alors
par rapport à la compétition va revenir
à la compétition d'ici au week-end ya
une spécificité je crois c'est le vol 4
b vous me disiez
le vol cadets on en a vu un petit peu au
départ du reportage c'est principalement
utilisé dans le dans les figures libres
ça permet à l'avion de reculer donc
c'est ce qui est peut-être le plus
spectaculaire pour les téléspectateurs
quelque chose est
assez peu courant de voir la vue ont
reculé quoi alors à côté de l'avion est
bien évidemment votre radio commande
c'est un peu votre coque pitt avoue tout
à fait dire tout à fait oui c'est avec
ça qu'on pilote l'avion bon maintenant
ça devient pour arriver à faire des
figures propre on arrive à programmer
chaque phase de vol avec des
débattements différents suivant la
figure qu'on veut faire ça ça se compose
de quoi une radiocommande si on la
connaît en fait vous avez les
si ça ne marche pas je vais l'apprendre
comme ça les téléspectateurs vont
l'avoir racontez nous un petit buzz vous
avez les quatre mondes les deux les deux
manches principaux là qui sont ceux sur
le bas qui permettre de
de commander le moteur les ailerons donc
l'inclinaison de l'avion la direction et
la profondeur de l'avion et après au
dessus vous avez une rangée de boutons
justement qui permettent de basculer
d'une d'une phase à une autre est aussi
un petit écran et voilà ça c'est pour la
programmation d'un outil technologique
où se situent nos pilotes français parce
qu'on va sûrement voir ce week-end aux
clayes-sous-bois est ce qu'ils sont dans
le top 2 mondial ou pas oui justement
donc on a eu les premiers championnats
du monde de la spécialité l'année
dernière en allemagne donc le champion
du monde en parle a dit andy individuel
l'égard de broc man and autrichien le
champion du monde junior était aux
quatre autres français et l'équipe de
france a fini championne du monde par
équipes on est plutôt plus au très bon
avant d'être champion j'imagine qu'il
faut aussi apprendre les bases
du pilotage quelles sont elles qu'est-ce
qu'on quelles sont les clefs condamne
aux débutants déjà arrivé à faire
décoller son avion le faire voler en
intérieur sont tapés dans les murs et
j'ai fait évident du tout je vous
garantis pu le faire à terré proprement
déjà à partir du moment où on arrive à
faire ça on compte peut commencer à
envisager de faire des figures votre
sport ne souffre pas de la concurrence
des jeux vidéo des simulateurs de vol
parce que là c'est du concret mais les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui est bien tout ce
qui est virtuel eux servent justement il
ya il existe de pas mal de ses
simulateurs de vol de mode
d'aéromodélisme et que nous on conseille
aux aux jeunes qui arrivent de
travailler dessus justement pour les
collages ça développe les réflexes sans
avoir la crainte de casser son avion
alors pour pour conclure pour revenir
sur cette compétition qui va avoir lieu
sur trois jours un vendredi samedi
dimanche au gymnase maurice baquet sur
l'épreuve libre dont vous parliez c'est
complètement la liberté totale du pilote
du pilote et puis on essaye de faire ce
qu'on veut en fait c'est vraiment ça
c'est un peu le programme comme en
patinage artistique c'est un peu
semblable patinage artistique et mais là
c'est vraiment des figures complètement
débridée avec une audace incroyable
certaines fois c'est vraiment quelque
chose de sensationnel à voir et comme on
voit sur sur les images là il n'y a pas
la musique mais tout à l'heure dans
l'extrait en voyait aussi on entendait
la musique il faut épouser à chaque fois
les notes de musique c'est important
pour avoir des bonnes notes justement
parlement il ay ay sont jugés en libre
sur le sur la qualité du vol sur la
variété des figures sur l'audace et sur
la synchronisation avec la musique très
bien merci beaucoup philippe pour cet
éclairage est donc rendez vous pour les
passionnés au gymnase maurice baquet ce
week end vendredi samedi dimanche toute
la journée
c'est ouvert au public aux
clayes-sous-bois dès vendredi matin
merci beaucoup je sais moi qui le
remercie je tiens à préciser que
l'entrée est gratuite pour le public
très bien c'est noté on sera présent
sans transition créant en polynésie on
passe aux arts martiaux l'alto est un
art martial méconnu réunissant de
nombreuses techniques de combat pratiqué
par une centaine d'illinois tout juste
la discipline tenta à s'ouvrir au plus
grand nombre grâce au self défense
images de tonate envie de garder son
calme parler avant d'agir il se défendre
au cas d'insistance de l'agresseur ce
sont les trois règles de l'alto une
discipline de self défense qui s'inspire
de tous les arts martiaux pour les
combattants confirmé la partie sportive
a vraiment les intéressés parce que nous
avons toutes les dimensions nous avons
chez nous beaucoup d'anciens de jb je
suis dos au kick boxing qui veulent voir
toutes les dimensions du combat ça c'est
un gros intérêt pour eux et ils peuvent
conserver bien sur leur origine et leur
savoir faire d'abord réservé aux
professionnels de la sûreté de la
sécurité les pratiquants naito arrive
désormais sur le tatami pour élargir
leur palette technique de combattants en
cas d'agression comme denis venu aux
arts martiaux par le taekwondo et
l'aïkido qu'à sa défense contre atiqi si
ça tourne vraiment dans spontanément
d'avoir des bases solides le fait de
connaître une palette technique se
savoir se comporter saïx et des
situations qu'on peut quand même
rencontrer dans leur quotidien créons
polynésie l'aito signifie guerrier cet
archétype du perfectionnement de soin
traditionnel dans les arts martiaux
associe également la modernité du cadre
de la légitime défense défini par la loi
on va apprendre l'article 225 du code
pénal sur la légitime défense et on va
leur rabâcher de rabâcher nos élèves
pour qu'ils comprennent que sur la loi
martiale dans la cdppt ans il yal'avant
la préparation la connaissance de la loi
cependant si on fait agresser que faire
et après les tout ce qui va être sur le
judiciaire pénal 4 club accueille une
centaine d'adhérents dans les yvelines
d'ailleurs très apprécié par notre
chargé de production et mais
présentatrice de l'émission cause
kiosque allez on passe tout de suite aux
résultats du week-end
en rugby c'est et le choc tant attendu
de cette saison et de cette 16e journée
de fédérale 3 plaisir deuxième se
déplacer sur la pelouse du troisième
pontault combault et le prc est sorti
vainqueur d'un match très tendu 13,7
avec notamment un essai inscrit grâce à
cette 13e victoire de la saison les
joueurs de philippe behar assurent leur
deuxième place au classement général que
vous voyez sa fiche est de cette poule 2
ils ont désormais 60 points et surtout
vous le voyez 15 points 15 longueurs
d'avancé sur proto cobo de quoi
envisager sereinement un premier match
de playoffs plus abordable face un
troisième de poule en football 9e
journée en retard de division d'honneur
versailles est allé s'imposer au blanc
mesnil par le plus petit des scores 1-0
les versaillais sont cinquièmes de leur
poule en promotion d'honneur il y avait
un match en retard de la 11e journée de
la poule b trappe 7e recevait le 11e
garges-lès-gonesse au stade gilbert
gensac peut être encore un peu sonné par
la démission collective de la présidence
dont mustapha larbaoui en tête les
joueurs trappistes se sont fait
surprendre par l'avant-dernier
valdoisiens mené 2 1 à la mi temps les
trappistes ont poussé en seconde période
et se procurent plusieurs occasions
notamment sur un coup franc qui passe de
peu à côté de la lucarne vous le voyez
tout juste à côté mais ils se font
surprendre en contre sur ce débordement
côté gauche que vous allez voir
apparaître à l'écran le gardien ni mal
la trajectoire du centre à ras de terre
et encaissent un troisième but score
final 3 buts à 1 malgré cette défaite
trappe conserve tout de même sa septième
place
toujours en football cette semaine se
jouer quelques matchs des huitièmes de
finale de la coupe des yvelines et
notamment l'équipe réserve de trappes
qui s'est imposé à domicile face à
l'équipe b du peg 2 buts à 1 rendez vous
le 16 mars pour les quarts de finale
chez les femmes il y avait un match en
retard de la 7e journée de promotion
d'honneur et l'encours se déplacer chez
le 2e parisien les amazones se sont
inclinés de justesse 2 buts à 1 les
joueuses de dany l'aigle perd une place
au classement ils sont désormais
septièmes handball on reste dans le
sport féminin on suit évidemment
montigné en nationale 2 14e journée les
mots génie monteyne recevait le neuvième
bar-le-duc et elles ont renoué avec la
victoire 25 17 avec ce huitième succès
de la saison elles sont désormais
quatrièmes de leur poule 5e journée de
phase finale du championnat de france
des moins de 18 ans toujours en handball
plaisir recevait le leader créteil à
pierre de coubertin ce dimanche si les
plis 0 les plaisirs roi en noir sur
l'écran entame très bien la rencontre en
menant même après un quart d'heure de
jeu le demi finaliste de la saison
passée va peu à prendre peu à peu un
pardon prendre l'ascendant pour mener 16
12 à la pause au retour des vestiaires
l'impact physique et l'expérience des
cristoliens fait la différence et ce
malgré huit buts de martin renaud la
logique a été respectée à pierre de
coubertin victoire de créteil 35 à 27
malgré cette défaite plaisir conserve sa
troisième place au classement général je
vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter
l'entraîneur des plaisirs roi au micro
dé l'ennemi moines après le match on a
une équipe jeune
j'apprends de match en match qui ceux
qui ne lâchent rien jusqu'au bout et on
n'était pas loin à chaque fois la fin à
quatre minutes à quatre buts à cinq
minutes encore on est à quatre buts donc
voilà on va en sera que nous avons dans
notre jeu rapide on marque beaucoup de
buts là dessus on donne tout ce qu'on a
c'est dommage parce qu'au début du match
mais 12-10 donc on voit bien qu'on est
on est un peu en panne et qu'on les met
en difficulté après la fatigue nous nous
rattrapons petit peu sur la fin du match
en basket il n'y avait pas de
championnat cette semaine mais de la
coupe de france trophée de coupe de
france c'est les féminines de l'entente
le chesnay versailles avait l'occasion
de se changer les idées avec les 32e de
finale les joueuses de stéphane drolet
accueillait la glacerie pensionnaire de
nationale 2 et elles se sont inclinées
de cinq petits points 80 à 76 il ne leur
reste plus qu'à espérer un miracle en
championnat pour se maintenir en
nationale une une dernière info c'est du
tennis de table et un grand bravo à
audrey zarif joueuses de cet été aux
d'elancourt en tennis de table grâce à
de belles performances en république
tchèque la pongiste saint-quentinoise de
14 ans je le rappelle est international
junior a validé son billet pour les jeux
olympiques de la jeunesse qui se
dérouleront du 16 au 28 août prochain en
chine une qualification assortie d'un
d'une probable montée en proie que l'on
suit attentivement avec son club qui
donne le ton à une excellente saison
pour l'instant on passe pour terminer à
votre agenda du week-end pour terminer
ce set 8 sport et de rendez vous à ne
pas rater vendredi samedi dimanche on en
parlait tout à l'heure la cinquième
édition de l'eee top cette compétition
internationale de modélisme et de
voltige indoor où les meilleurs pilotes
du monde seront réunies il y aura
soixante trois pilotes présents ce week
end rendez vous au gymnase maurice
baquet aux clayes sous bois en football
match en retard de la 15e journée de
promotion d'honneur guyancourt reçoit
ini au stade maurice baquet coup d'envoi
à 15h30 c'est la première rencontre des
guyancourt toit après le décès du
dirigeant émile le gâte c'est la fin de
ce set 8 fort merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à le
commenter sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag le 7-8 sport tout attaché sur
twitter évidemment mais merci de l'avoir
encore une fois suivi on se retrouve
lundi prochain même lieu même heure